- Welcome to Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation.
My name is John Watrous, and I'm the technical director
of IBM Quantum Education.
The purpose of this series is to provide you with
a solid understanding of quantum information and computation, and that means getting
into the technical details
of quantum information and seeing how quantum
computing really works, what it can do and what it can't do.
If you haven't already
watched the overview video for this series, I encourage you to check that out.
In that video, you'll find information about what sort of background
preparation is recommended for this series, as well as an outline of
the topics to be covered.
Also, be sure to check
out the Qiskit textbook, which covers the same
material as this video series in a written form,
and it also includes
interactive components and interfaces to hardware and software designed to help you to better understand
quantum information and computation. You'll find links to the overview video and the Qiskit textbook
in the description.
This is lesson one of
unit one of the series.
Unit one covers the basics
of quantum information, and in the first lesson of this unit, we'll focus on how
quantum information works
for single systems, meaning that we have
just one physical system or a device of some sort that
stores quantum information
and we're considering how that
one system or device works in isolation.
In the lesson following this one, we'll discuss how
quantum information works when we have multiple systems and that will allow us
to describe interesting
and important concepts such as quantum algorithms that make use of multiple qubits
and quantum protocols
involving multiple individuals that process quantum information and transmit it back and
forth to one another.
But before getting into those discussions, it makes sense to start with the
comparatively simple setting of a single system in isolation,
partly because it's good to start simple, but also because as we will see, the description of how
quantum information works
for single systems in isolation leads very naturally and logically to the description of how
for multiple systems.
Here's a brief overview of the lesson.
We're gonna start by discussing
classical information.
Now, the purpose of this lesson is not to explain how
classical information works, it's to explain how
quantum information works,
but to explain how
quantum information works, it's very helpful to begin
with classical information and to use it as a
familiar point of reference
when we discuss quantum information.
At a mathematical level, quantum and classical information actually have pretty similar descriptions with some key differences, of course.
In fact, quantum information
really isn't separate from classical information at all.
It's an extension of
classical information.
The fact of the matter
is, at least in my view, that you really can't
understand quantum information if you don't understand
classical information,
so starting with classical
information makes sense.
I do expect that this
content will be familiar to some viewers, but even if you are familiar with it, I don't recommend that you skip it.
In addition to highlighting the aspects of classical information that are most relevant to
understanding quantum information, we're gonna introduce the
Dirac notation in this part,
which is a standard way
that we're gonna use to describe vectors and
matrices throughout the series.
As it turns out, the Dirac notation isn't
specific to quantum information.
It can equally well be used in the context of classical information as well as many other settings where vectors and matrices arise.
We'll then move on to quantum information, and specifically, we'll
discuss the representation of quantum states as vectors,
a simple type of measurement called a standard basis measurement, and unitary operations, which describe discreet time
changes in quantum systems.
Again, all in the setting
of single systems.
Before we get started with lesson itself, it will be helpful to clarify that there are actually two descriptions
of quantum information, the simplified description, which is what we'll be
focusing on in this lesson
and throughout this first unit and the general description, which is covered in a later unit, specifically in the
third unit of the series.
The simplified description,
true to its name, is simpler and it's
typically learned first.
In the simplified description, as I've already suggested, quantum states are represented by vectors and operations are represented
by unitary matrices.
This description of quantum
information is sufficient for an understanding of
most quantum algorithms, for instance,
so it isn't oversimplified, it's the real thing.
However, as we will
discover as we go along, it does have some limitations.
For instance, if we wanna
model the effects of noise on quantum systems, this description turns out to be lacking.